we checked recent news about a black
hole that's just isolated with a whole
trail of stars like just discovered it
is very cool and it's not super in our
backyard it's actually about eight
billion light years away oh well okay so
it's a day's trip yeah the story that
we've got is that there might be three
black holes involved in this whole
situation was totally unexpected the
people who found it were not looking for
it and they got this weird line you
don't see a lot of straight lines in the
universe and just to be clear yeah this
is evidence that we can discover things
we're not looking for sometimes science
is like looking for your keys it's like
you you lost your keys you go looking
for them you're like look at that twenty
dollars look at that
foreign
[Music]